hey youtubers is Charlie welcome to my
forever evil edition of anime club last
time I talked about my favorite anime
characters overall and a lot of evil
characters made a list so I thought it'd
be fun to do a video just about evil
characters
I mean who among us hasn't rolled a Sith
Warrior in Knights of the Old Republic
Walter White from Breaking Bad even
became one of the most popular
characters in the world last year and he
was completely evil by the end the thing
that all the best evil characters have
in common though is that they do not see
themselves as evil everyone's always the
protagonist of their own story it's only
once you zoom out and look at all of the
characters in the series that you find
that the story is not always being told
from their perspective which is why they
become the villains real quick to the
random winners from last week's anime
club video though aPOPO the wet snow you
win the Amazon gift card and the milling
you get to choose a future anime club
topic I'll be reaching out to both you
guys in your channels this week the
prize is the same a $20 Amazon gift card
to one random subscriber in the comments
and one will get to choose a future
anime club topic so let's get started
first I'm going to do my top 5 evil
anime characters then I'm going to list
a few brand-new anime series where the
protagonist is evil so everyone raise
your glasses gentlemen to evil bonus
points if you can guess which animated
show that that line is taken from number
5 Griffith from berserk he killed all of
his companions to become femto the fifth
member of the God Hand and committed
some really awful atrocities against his
former best friend guts before he was
tortured for seducing the princess you
could say that he was just a really
selfish person that eventually went
insane but because of his crimson bow
helot you could also say that there was
this predestiny aspect to him becoming a
true villain that's just the nature
versus nurture argument that all
villains have in common it's just a
question that says are you a villain
because you are born that way or because
your environment and the people around
you made you a villain number 4
Johann liebert from Monster guilty on
all counts of psychological crimes
against humanity the term villain is
usually applied to big monsters
you-know-who physically attack other
people you know who chase after things
but sometimes psychological attacks are
even worse because they cause people to
act out on themselves
Johan twists Minds indiscriminately not
to be outdone by casual monsters he also
does you know just outright murder
people considered to be friends and
family I would
he's like the Joker of the monster
series but he actually does have a grand
plan and the Joker is really just an
agent of chaos now it's time for my top
three villains in order to make the list
I separated characters that were just
plain evil
from characters that were evil geniuses
in order to be classified as such they
needed to have won a grand design - all
the best monologues and three of flair
for the dramatic that would make Loki
you know Tom Hiddleston is loki bow and
submission and so here goes number three
the major from Helsing ultimate all you
need to do to understand him is watch
his war speech from episode four
not only does he have a grand design he
loves he revels in the act of atrocity
the fact that he's a Nazi just makes it
easier to visually identify him as a
villain but it's really speeches like
the one that I just mentioned that set
him apart
quick sub note for my top - in order to
go from being just a plain old evil
genius to being one of the best evil
characters of all time you have to begin
to wield the power of God your character
also has to be fairly ambiguous you know
the evil characters like I said don't
always see themselves as evil so number
two father from Full Metal Alchemist
Brotherhood all that he wants is to know
everything there is to know and he uses
his nearly limitless power to achieve
his such because he's immortal
over the course of time he's become like
this plague this hell on earth he
unleashes the seven deadly sins from
himself then kills those children so to
speak pieces of himself whenever it
suits him what's worse he takes the face
of the hero
even though Edward and Alphonse are
arguably the protagonist of the series
father took Hohenheim space and they're
gonna eventually look like Hohenheim so
he really took their faces he's such a
good character that you even cheer for
him just a little bit when he almost
achieves his goal because what's wrong
with wanting to know everything and my
number one anime villain Light Yagami
from Death Note because what's worse
than a hero that becomes a villain
through the course of his actions father
from Brotherhood was arguably born evil
even if it was kind of ambiguous but
light actually started with a very noble
quest to get rid of all evil so
technically he was trying to do good but
he's so single-minded in his quest that
he'd kill his own family if they tried
to stop him which becomes this really
elegant contradiction of the series you
try to protect your loved ones by
getting rid of all evil but you end up
killing them when they try to stop you
because you've become evil it's this
really awesome self-fulfilling prophecy
that's common amongst all heroes that
end up turning into villains now it's
your turn let me know who is your
favorite and my villain in the comments
below as I mentioned before he
there are a few suggestions for new
anime series where the protagonist is a
villain first is the devil is a
part-timer the premise is actually kind
of funny the devil is trapped in the
body of a human with none of his powers
so he has to get a job at a fast-food
restaurant so he can live the hero
actually ends up getting a job as a
telemarketer so that he can try and keep
him in check it's just funny because
these really epic characters doing the
most mundane of things it's actually
streaming for free on the Funimation
site my number 2 suggestion is flowers
of evil the protagonist is a normal
human student who becomes this really
dark character after getting humiliated
by his classmates the animation is
really different and the pace is really
slow so it's a lot different from devil
as a part-timer it just depends on what
kind of anime you like to watch it does
look really interesting though and you
can watch it on crunchyroll right now
feel free to make any recommendations
for anime series that you really like
where the main character is a villain
next week for anime club I think I'm
going to focus specifically on a tech on
Titan because that's streaming on
Netflix now so everybody should have had
a chance to watch it
we are still crossing our fingers for
that season 2 though in other big news
Walking Dead is back tonight so be sure
and watch it I'm doing another weekly
giveaway for that show so you have
another chance to win something I'll be
posting a review video after the episode
airs tonight right now you can click
here to learn about my top 10 anime
characters overall not just the evil
characters and you can click here to get
my top 5 Miyazaki films thank you so
much for watching I'll see you guys
tonight high fives